ever since its world-shattering and
window-shattering debut at the la auto
show there hasn't been anything to come
out that's as iconic as tesla's very own
cybertruck
and while the design brand heritage and
just sheer feel of the thing might say
to some people that the truck is the
future of four-wheel drive vehicles that
might not be the case because folks the
truth is that no matter how impressive
the first model was the tesla cyber
truck is far from being complete and
anyone who's made a deposit or is in
line to buy it might be regretting that
decision already and a big part of the
reason for that is not tesla's
difficulty in producing the truck but
the massive competition faced by those
guys because as it turns out right now
there are not one not two but multiple
alternatives to the tesla cyber truck
that might not only be just as good but
even better than elon's great whale and
so in this video we're going to be
taking a look at five of the most
promising electronic suvs coming in the
future that have the potential to
dethrone the cyber truck entirely and so
to kick things off let's name the
company everyone is probably already
thinking about one the rivian r1s
the brainchild of mit phd holder robert
scarange rivien has often been cited as
tesla's most prominent rival with many
people comparing the two to the likes of
xbox and playstation and if you take a
look at the company's business model and
practices it's not hard to see why you
see while tesla's goal has been to
create an ev conglomerate something like
toyota that makes luxury cars and sedans
and sporty coops among everything rivien
has a much more focused approach and its
focus is on the same spot as the cyber
truck that being the high utility
vehicle market with stuff like suvs and
trucks and the results of that approach
are the r1t pickup and the r1s suv both
of which debuted at the la auto show the
same venue where the cyber truck was
revealed
[Music]
and while on paper they both seem pretty
similar rivian seems to have a business
idea completely different from tesla you
see instead of trying to sell you on
some brand new futuristic design the
entire idea behind rivien is to make evs
especially in the form of these rugged
day-to-day type vehicles far more
approachable as a result their designs
don't look half as otherworldly as tesla
despite still being modestly futuristic
and honestly really good to look at as a
result of this they also don't face the
production issues that musk cybertruck
is facing and wouldn't you know it
despite being released in the same time
frame the rivian suv is already in its
delivery stage with this 316 mile range
suv with state-of-the-art interiors and
the ability to gain 140 miles of range
after just 20 minutes of charging all
for 70 000 right now it's no wonder
people are flocking to them add to that
the fact that massive companies like
ford and amazon are already betting
their dollars on the company with the
former automaker investing 500 million
in the startup while musk's most direct
competitor jeff bezos taking a 20 stake
in the company and ordered 100 000
delivery van vehicles based on the r1
models in 2019 a whole year before the
expected production so all in all while
rivien might not have the most high-tech
or outrageous design that most people
think of when they imagine tesla killer
the more subdued and mature approach
might just make rivien the king of
electric suvs long before tesla even
gets its cyber truck affairs in order
now if you were a little disappointed
with rivien being a calmer tesla don't
worry because our next pick is sure to
fulfill those dreams of yours 2. edison
future ef1v
founded very recently in 2020 it's not
hard to understand why many people are
considering this startup to be just that
another startup but take a look at the
company's background and more
importantly their actual products and
i'm sure you will change your mind you
see edison future is not like tesla or
rivien in the sense that instead of
being a brand new company made by a
special team edison is the collective
endeavor of two already existing
companies and not just any companies but
companies with a financial backing and
technical experience that is actually
greater than even tesla these are the
california-based phoenix motor cars and
chinese energy brand spi energy and
their collective efforts have yielded
something truly spectacular straight
from the get-go the design by ukona
design styling is striking with
futuristic lines and most prominently an
absolutely massive size and that's also
where you'll notice that the ef-1v is
actually not a regular suv but instead
more like a van but don't let that fool
you because this bad boy is not only
more spacious than any current suv it
has a few tricks up its sleeve that not
only lift it up from the level of a van
but even above standard suvs the most
prominent of these the solar roof that's
right a solar roof has been installed on
these cars and using that it can
regenerate mileage in mildly sunny
conditions using nothing more than
natural sunlight and then there's the
power and the main reason i consider it
to be an suv the drivetrain with
four-wheel drive providing a massive 816
horsepower to get a total of a
mind-numbing 11 000 pound towing
capacity and the huge bed of the vehicle
acting as a super battery that can give
you an unheard of 450 miles range all
with an interior that's as flashy as it
is luxurious it's hard not to be
impressed by the company and then there
are the completely unnecessary bits like
a launch time that's equal to a porsche
911 at 3.9 seconds and a 4 000 cubic
feet cargo space and with the
aforementioned support from its parent
companies i personally think that the
upper segment of the market might
already have their massive suv and it's
not a tesla now that we've covered a
space-age masterpiece an all-american
standard truck i think it's time we take
a look at the more rugged ways of life
in the three bollinger b1
if you saw the price tag of the rivian
and thought that it was too mundane for
your taste and if you saw the sleek
silver body of yedison ef-1v and thought
meh then don't worry because we have
just the pick for you because the
bollinger b1 doesn't only have an
obscene price tag of 125 thousand
dollars it has the most bonkers design
of any ev that i have ever laid my eyes
on with a brick shaped chassis with
manually removable rectangular glass and
metal panels that means exactly what you
think it does this baby can be driven
window and ruthless and if the design
alone did not speak of rugged military
utility the sparsity of the interior
which comes without an air conditioner
by default and the sheer obscene kinds
of off-road specs definitely do from a
trick hydropneumatic suspension that
controls body roll taking straight out
setups and trick supercars to portal
axles an off-road vehicle trick used to
boost ground clearance and reduce torque
on various drivetrain components and
that doesn't mean that this guy is
lackluster electrically either because
they will have 142 kilowatt hour battery
pack that at the right charger can fill
up completely in just 75 minutes add to
all that
horsepower and 668 pound-foot torque
powertrain driving 0-60 times in 4.5
seconds and an electronically limited
top speed of 100 miles an hour a 7
500 pound towing capacity a 5 000 pound
payload capacity and 10 to 20 inches of
variable ground clearance it's pretty
clear why the thing costs so much and
with deliveries having already begun the
tesla cyber truck is suddenly looking a
lot less appealing now wrapping up to
the end we have two quite similar but at
the same time quite different evs that
have a different thing going for them
brand security let's start with the four
ford explorer ev
long reigning as one of the kings of the
ev suv world it's about time ford came
up with an suv to challenge the likes of
tesla and no we're not talking about the
mustang e-type instead what we think is
going to be the actual breadwinner of
the company is an upcoming ev based on
the ford explorer and that alone should
be enough to tell you why the thing is
primed for success because you see the
explorer is the best-selling three-row
suv in america for a reason it's
reliable risk-free and simple and by
bringing that model into the electric
world faster than tesla can yell
autopilot it's not a surprise that many
experts already consider it the future
of electric suvs add all of that to the
fact that it's ford motors and it's an
electric explorer for nearly thirty
thousand dollars only i don't think we
should have any doubts about that and
that brings us to the last but not the
least the
five gmc hummer
gmc is one of the longest running car
brands in the world and with them owning
so many iconic brands it's no surprise
that they found a way to incorporate
their newfound electric streak into an
existing property and the result of that
is the gmc hummer ev a thousand
horsepower three electric motor platform
that brings the hummer into a completely
new era and with the design offering
removable roof panels optional
adjustable air suspension and a unique
four wheel steering feature that allows
it to crab sideways or drive diagonally
it's not hard to see the hummer
character underneath all of that
electric glamour add to all that the
estimated range of 350 miles per charge
and a 0 to 60 time of only 3.0 seconds
and finally with a proper infotainment
system on its 13.4 inch display designed
by epic games of all people the hummer
might just take the spot for the most
well-rounded of these options and with
that i think we should wrap up the video
i hope you enjoyed watching it and if
you did be sure to leave a like and
subscribe for more if you want to learn
more about mercedes eqs the most
luxurious electric car click on the
video right here on the screen with that
take care and i'll see you guys next
time